the most dangerous men on the planet who
I've worked with whether they were
Rangers or seals three-letter agency
contractors that work with all kinds of
really dangerous dudes and at the very
tippy top of those guys they're always
these more humble unassuming guys and
I'm like what is that and you realize
the Arrogant guy can only get so tough
and it can only get so far but you have
to be teachable and to be teachable
arrogance will only let you get so far
in that respect and so I saw a lot of
guys who were kind of PT studs they'd
get into ranger battalion and then
they'd wash out and then some other guy
with less impressive physique but he's
got a longer suffering grit and
character under the hood he had deeper
reservoirs and a soul to tap into that
dude didn't quit and he went the
distance we find Incredible strength
through humility and I do press and it's
not all fluffy metaphorical stuff I go
into some real brass tacks of like hey
let's be tough guys in the more obvious
and traditional sense as well